nearly 10 months after invading Ukraine
Russia has been frozen out of many
markets International sanctions have
limited the goods coming in but having
caused the economic collapse that some
predicted so we have a boost of
inflation in
in Spring
it was cost
primarily by by this
disrupted Logistics
ah decline of import so big inflation in
import
that's the first
impact
a second impact
on on labor force
uh the
thedrawal of western western companies
in some sectors
is a social media manager born and
raised in Moscow the these days she
spends time at the mall not for pleasure
but because she's searching for
Essentials
[Music]
the main problem is that what you've
become accustomed to for a long time has
either become more expensive or left the
market so you have to accept the new
price or look for substitutes from other
manufacturers
Outlets of some International brands are
full of stock but closed others have
been renamed this coffee shop is now
called stars and a recognizable Burger
chain
iska which translates as tasty and
that's it
Western Brands used to dominate almost
every mall and High Street in Moscow and
other major cities the post-soviet
generation has been plugged into Global
Trends so it's going to be difficult for
them to disconnect but it's more
complicated when it comes to
manufacturing and Technology
you need technology
so and you need to get this technology
from somewhere
and if we are seeing seeing the
withdrawal of
technologically advanced companies from
Russia
so it's very difficult to substitute
[Music]
the government has launched vehicle and
pharmaceutical manufacturing plans and
announced plans to increase investment
into technology development and
artificial intelligence
since you can buy everything from nails
to Diamonds you'll never produce your
own so the current situation is pushing
us to work independently in many areas
including the production of our own
scientific and instrumental base
the president's plans are ambitious but
observers warn International sanctions
could squeeze Russia's industrial
capacity for years to come Moscow